-We're all so excited that the
Olympics are here.
And of course we're pumped for
all the big events.
But there's one event that
doesn't always
get the most attention.
Until now.
Take a look.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ You think that all Olympic
sports are glory golden fame ♪
♪ They're not ♪
-♪ But there is one ♪
♪ That stands above
that isn't playing games ♪
-♪ No more games ♪
♪ Forget the slopes,
forget the ice ♪
♪ No, I'm not in the mood ♪
-♪ Not tonight ♪
-♪ Because I want
to sing about tonight ♪
♪ Is doubles luge ♪
-♪ Two birds one sled ♪
♪ Try to stay alive ♪
♪ Bodysuit skin tight ♪
♪ Spooning while we drive ♪
-♪ Spooning ♪
-♪ First sprint then slide ♪
♪ The hard work never ends ♪
♪ We shoot through
all the tubes ♪
♪ Just like a colon cleanse ♪
-♪ Oh, wow ♪
-♪ Flying fast, making turns ♪
♪ In sync with my teammate ♪
♪ I whisper in his ear ♪
♪ You're really doing great ♪
♪ Milliseconds for the win ♪
♪ We simply cannot lose ♪
-♪ Don't lose ♪
-♪ Pelvis on pelvis ♪
♪ That is doubles luge ♪
-♪ Again ♪
-♪ Pelvis on pelvis ♪
♪ That is doubles luge ♪